there was you know there was a thing
that happened I remember being around on
that set even though I wasn't in the
scene but when you did the whole attic
scene where Clarke goes up we did that
and reckon Ridge because we couldn't get
out of it it was very moving and I
remember that you guys approached that
you had a lot of input input into them
oh you did I remember what he made I act
as a thing I know but you were I winged
it but he was talking from a very very
deep place and I was very proud of you
all I know is look let me explain this
to the family we were in Breckenridge to
do the always snow stuff you know it's a
lot of fun but bingo anyway we couldn't
get out because there was a huge
snowstorm and we there was nowhere to go
and we were supposed to being back here
but we looked up and there was an addict
there and it seemed to be fine well
we'll just do the Attic
seen in this attic and I was I was very
happy because it allowed me to do
something I wanted to do with my life
which is step on a board and haven't hit
me and then step back and have the other
one hit me I love that stuff it was very
nice and Jeremiah made it look kind and
warm and and the right time to fall
through was perfect Ray Charles was
singing but it was a scene that really
beautiful singing that was Rachel that
was a beautiful scene Jenny yeah that's
one of the most beautiful scenes in a
movie
it is so poignant it shows like your
depth it's beautiful
until she does this and it really laughs
it really lets you into Y heap it means
so much to him to give this Christmas to
his family I just thought it was
beautiful
[Applause]